the poorest country in the Americas is
on lockdown Haiti's airports schools
factory and seaports are closed worried
shoppers are stocking up with basic
supplies I'm asking all of you to stay
calm even if you heard everything is
shutting down goods will continue to
come to the country we ask everyone to
follow the advice of the government to
prevent the worst president quo Vanel
moist said the two patients who tested
positive are in quarantine and came from
abroad
but the pandemic is expected to hit
Haiti's crumbling healthcare system hard
there are just over a hundred intensive
care beds available for the ten million
people that live here two-thirds of the
population don't have access to decent
sanitation regular hand washing is a
luxury the state of emergency is being
enforced to stop new cases but health
care workers are concerned it could also
prevent medical supplies and volunteer
doctors from coming in we don't have
supplies we haven't even heard from the
Ministry of Health
we don't have gloves or masks to face
the virus in 2010 UN peacekeepers were
responsible for bringing and cholera to
the country at least 10,000 people died
cholera caused major damages in Haiti
with the arrival of the corona virus in
the face of major crisis we couldn't
contain cholera and will be even worse
with a corona virus gas stations ran out
of fuel on Friday
Katy's fight against kovat 19 is likely
to be brutal Leah Harding al-jazeera